hi everyone we're Laney and we're gonna
be talking about our firsts first time
you all met each other I met Jake at the
YMCA in green hills Nashville Tennessee
Jake was living in a house with less and
I think the first time I came over I met
him here at the house
Jake played drums for a couple brothers
that were in a band and I lived with
those brothers Jake would come over and
crash on the futon so we would hang out
quite a bit never talked about being in
the band together I moved to LA
somewhere in that process these two
started making music as a band called
worlds without the oh and they were kind
of getting some coal steam online with
some blogs and I was getting no steam
and I was in LA and I called Jake I was
like whatever you're doing is obviously
working can I come to Nashville and just
write a few songs for you guys you can
see what happens I flew to Nashville
March of 2014 we had four days together
wrote and recorded our first two songs I
had a first fan fight you had it within
the first day there you go you know we
wrote one song called hot lights we all
loved it then I started writing this one
called walk away and that's was like I
can't do know where this is going yeah
and then Jake was Jake came home cuz he
was like in the studio working on
another project and then he's like well
let me just play some drums over top and
then I get so much sense yeah anyways we
put our first two songs on the Internet
April 22nd 2014 and now we're here at
BuzzFeed five years later first
laney show ooh our very first was down
in San Diego it was a singer it was like
a secret show we didn't even put our
name on the bill we wanted to go by
Outback Steakhouse because we'd never
played a show and we wanted to have
three practice shows below our first
show at the sailor's club which was like
the first week of February
but we went down to San Diego name
wasn't even on the bill and Dan showed
up and we're like we had five songs so
this show was about 12 minutes long yeah
I used to have the shakes so bad like my
knees just like you know so nervous but
that was a really really cool show where
we started with hot lights and I sang
the first verse in the wrong team that
is so nervous but we ended great first
kiss Ashley painter fourth grade
what's up just kiss cuz we got 100 on
the quiz maybe yeah I think I was eight
through ninth grade I kissed a sweet
girl named Tina Mooneyham my junior prom
this girl named Lauren Morris I had
known her since second grade I actually
this is a pretty good story we got time
freshman year of high school and there's
this big hill where I'm from in Tulsa
and my buddy took me there and I was
like I'm gonna bring Lauren here one of
these days and I'm gonna kiss her and
she's gonna be the first girl ever kiss
fast forward two years later took her to
prom then I was like hey I want to take
you somewhere put on a blindfold curated
a playlist drove her to this hill
carried her to this spot I was like two
years ago Lauren Morris I said is gonna
bring you here and kiss you and then BAM
just that first song you wrote this is
this comes back to Lauren Morrison every
time it was literally to ask Lauren the
problem that was my first song ever the
first song I wrote was a song that I
actually wrote with my dad oh my dad
brought some lyrics about his dad
actually about growing up yeah so when I
was younger I went to a camp in Pine
Bluff Arkansas and we all got to make
CDs in my studio is called gooses hip
hop and I had a song called cookie dough
because I was huge and I loved to eating
sweets first time someone recognized you
in public this is just now starting to
happen by the way well we went to London
and I
think we'd even play the show we just
were like there to take some meetings or
something like that it was just the
three of us and our manager and within
like 15 minutes of walking down the
street these these two girls ran up to
us I'm like oh my god are you that was
really early first time you heard one of
your songs in public I think well the
first time we heard one of our songs on
the radio which is only happen like any
times ever we were in Phoenix Arizona
and I was a really cool you know it
sounds different on the radio you know
there's something about it like I don't
know the science but it's definitely
like they they like squash the audio in
some way to send it further and you know
it's got a quality to it yeah yeah there
was a really cool moment first album you
ever bought a Boston CD classic rock
Banas room force where's John Mayer
think mine was Californication by the
Red Hot Chili Peppers first song you
wrote as a group hot lights I don't know
I was like obsessed with nothing was the
same by Drake so less than I had sat
there and he has this what do you call
it a cork cork Elektra
yeah it was a bunch of like samples and
we just started kind of building drum
sounds inspired by that first celebrity
crush
it's brad.leah
Jessica Alba nice pie the Olsen twins
I'm just gonna go grab it first crazy
fan interaction I sign a girl's forehead
one time and in a walkie which is just
like I think you really want me to do
this like please sign my forehead and
like yeah okay I think that's definitely
pretty pretty weird there's a bunch of
fans at the airport waiting for us and a
kid gave me a potato and so it's just
like : thank you so much was potato
first musical inspiration Michael
Jackson yeah yeah I would have to be
like John Mayer for me I'd say two chili
peppers yeah we played seven arenas with
John Mayer in 2017 I got this tattoo for
this
so as we play the same yep now we text
sometimes so great love you and then
chili peppers the drummer and Chad Smith
was that amoeba music one time unless
was there when we all lived together and
he sent me a text I forget where I was
but he's like hey chats Misenum even
music right now you should come and I
got on my bike and I sprinted to make
music and I went in and he was looking
at like a John Coltrane record so I
thought that was amazing and I just like
tapped him I was like I just want to say
you're like my biggest inspiration
behind a kid it was like oh thanks so
much yeah that's any touch my shoulder
how's it
[Music]